hello welcome to this broadcast I hope
you're all managed to be here on time
because it's a bit of an unusual time at
least if you in Europe yeah we haven't
had the daylight what is that daylight
saving time change yeah the DD st and
none in the u.s. we didn't have that yet
in Europe so it's slightly confusing for
the European views it's the same time as
usual for the American ones but in
Europe it's one hour earlier okay let's
get going with some games of chess I'm
really looking forward to play some
games start I haven't played today at
all so maybe kick off with the king porn
playing FM meditator okay I always get
requests for the Kings gamble okay let's
do 1 Kings gambit let's see what happens
I scored with that in the live streams
but someone is going for g5 but yeah
what is the move I think it's h4 all
right I think this is probably better
than Bishop c4 of it from here it all
gets very shady I think this is also a
move they call d5 now if i'm not
mistaken there should be six and then d
4 but around here it's it gets very very
I have no idea there is some night h5
sometimes and think why just castles
even though it looks like you
I think you castle here even though as I
said it looks completely bonkers twin
takes h4 how am I not losing their
whatever a weird opening I really often
wonder what the point is how what is
that I think it's castles but it looks
completely weird retakes h4 how am I not
losing their Queenie one maybe but I'm
two pods down or one pond no I'm one
pawn two points down hmm what a what is
there can i but if I don't castle he
plays 93 right this is this is looking
also totally insane I probably have to
cancel him even though it looks
completely completely charcoal pop queen
age for Homer not losing their 21 maybe
earlier and it takes crew takes Queenie
one Bishop if I take one half i already
have to invent this opening now here /
over the body I have no idea if I play
Bishop f4 he has g3 right and i'm using
right how am i not losing their Bishop
f4 g3
ok I play Bishop takes 2-3 then Knight
takes I don't get it g3 how do I not
lose here I probably wonders and what is
this guy it's wrong it's completely in
shock what I'm doing him I guess hmm how
am I not losing
Bishop edgy 393 has the screen age one
rupee one weekly one Shack it's also
totally totally losing anyway check now
the Kings gambit check the Kings gambit
is not not an opening you should play if
you have no idea and probably you
shouldn't play it if you have an idea
anyway so he will probably just move the
King now and now what's they have no
time this is particularly cool look
everyone i'm down a piece and some pawns
I have no time and my king is on c3
let's the Kings gambit folks who check
yeah but please this is this will be the
only totally wacky opening for the
session I don't want to win a game but
at least now and then not sure that 95
was the best move maybe it is well if I
get in queen age 5 I actually have some
some ideas okay
I'm not sure that he played this the
best possible way with I'm probably
still losing completely but at least I
have have some kind of idea now Luke
takes f 7j yeah I have to check with
this unfortunately otherwise i mated on
c2 but I have a maid threat now I have a
maid thread he's got Queen them to
defile oh yeah well I have checked yeah
i have a check time morning who is
playing this in a strange way Queen B 5
might still shinin though ft three lumps
retinue group takes you three now some
of this game is still on you can maybe
check on beef know which are gonna be
form should be three Bishop takes the
two that might win but check okay
Wow aight i was thinking it's a check
it's not a check oh I were total [ __ ] I
still had a position again ah and now i
blundered the Queen ah what a game I had
a completely ok position again I think
and then i blundered the bloody queen oh
my goodness goddamn i'm a full Queen
down here writing but he played that
song so weird I don't want to want to
give up I really had an ok position
again from that completely losing
nonsense i had a head at the beginning
so I feel I should continue here no one
is just protected what am i doing ah
what a coup again I swear I'm not drunk
absolutely not I didn't drink it single
beer or anything absolutely nothing ok I
have to resign that game so this much
for this for the comedy for the comedy
of this evening I think I should play a
little bit better now ok ah that was
crazy and every I hadn't for had a
position again this was this was the
weirdest part yeah after after that
totally totally moronic
opening okay so let's set let's try to
get a get a decent game here against
flama savita wherever that is but it's
high rated yeah Ricardo Rodriguez has
good game this is a funny way to put it
i think that was a rotten game but i
think it was probably it had some some
some comedic value yeah okay so what is
he doing here I'll be here I try to make
c5 tough to play or impossible to play
and we'll see if I manage yeah that
doesn't look like this is out of the
question they get 85 and 90 for or not
be three this as possible before I
somewhat weakened but the most important
thing still does the c 5 square okay the
trip to before so i think i'm going to
place it here by getting 95 that would
be desirable hmm right here on 95 is
also move but i think i think i'll jump
in okay is a 5 a move that helps
probably not that much
probably just rip ce 197 now you might
have 97 here but ok I can take on p7 and
grab c6 yeah the move a5 is probably not
doing much good hmm
greenbee three I can go queen bee three
this is not a bad move yeah maybe do
that just just insist on him taking okay
maybe he can go away five actually huh
you can go a fine I guess
yeah he can go 85 I didn't really
appreciate this that let it clearly k 5
is not not all great i mean it makes
c-54 him tougher to play ok yeah yeah I
have to take probably on d7 and now well
I cannot take what I can do this
threatening 8x b5 and c5 I can take b5 i
guess or sieve and bhai ok grips there
yeah c5 is still not possible i'm having
this under control i wonder if i should
move the ruthless somewhere
yeah wonder if he has some kind of five
anyway which I don't think so
yeah it looks okay for white but I don't
quite see how to improve he has a hard
time to place his 65 so but what am i
doing just goes back maybe he wants to
go and push it f6 I can go if I've
that's not a big deal
okay well I can't go Bishop d3 d4 maybe
but I'm still kind of worried that he
goes see five now I still have to do
that it's the only way forward ok now i
can take and play but surely for seems
like is losing a pawn not sure how we
should lose it c5 gives me a good see
porn and otherwise it also Jack looks
very difficult to defend if I take if I
get to just take c6
now I don't really see a good defense
for black here maybe rook rook c8 and
trade something this one okay
interesting okay I cannot really keep it
check so probably have to have to try to
check F sound him we gave eight is a
blunder so okay that was interested
interesting way of playing it it tries
to he will get the pawn on e5 and this
is has some fortress-like qualities
definitely covering the porn there
nicely on f7 I mean if you cannot do
much it is a purely defensive set up but
it's a sturdy one now someone says the
stream stopped okay maybe this is some
issue on my end yeah let me let me let
me see if I can do something here I
probably have gym morning have to do
something here
I sometimes have a problem here with the
with the disk space let me help me check
one thing you will be a little bit
tricky for that game I cannot do
everything at the same time it's back
now okay yeah I have lost time here
unfortunately because of that I've
managed to trade a rook which is very
helpful let me see it might be a draw
still but it seemed check check check
check oh shoot didn't see that one check
check me okay there was a bit lucky with
the time and okay so let me see um I
finished the game and I will check
something something briefly now I want
to check if I forgot everything covered
here let me check
sorry it takes the moon but I want to
make sure that i'm not running out of
disk speed or stuff like that ok so my
disk space should be ok now and I'm
ready for the next game I hope that the
stream is reliable now um okay um let's
see if there are questions advice for a
player with around 1,600 rating who get
good results with one deal with why's
that everyone gets bad positions out of
the opening with black hmm that's not so
easy to say it's um I would need to see
games to make a really good guess there
if you play one default enjoy kind of
let's say tidy strategic positions this
is sometimes the case um with default
players it might be that you play too
sharply with black and have to find
something a little bit more strategic
you focus but it's it's really really
difficult um okay as a question is it
necessary to have a chess base package
to be a serious chess player well not
not necessary but it is something yeah
after reaching a certain level it will
be very difficult without a database it
is simply very very useful you have
nowadays good good web resources but
it's still not the same as a database so
probably it's it's hard to get by
without one um is it worth getting the
IOC membership for around 1600 player
well it it definitely is something to
consider because as you see has got
ready
and I'm playing on opportunities you
just get many many games quickly and and
this is much easier than other side what
might be a more strategically focused
opening for black kind of a d4
equivalent um yeah the difficult thing
as always it depends it depends a little
bit there are many strategically focused
possible replies but they are also all
very different yeah even the Kings
Indian could be played as a very
strategic kind of opening even though it
has the reputation of being being sharp
um it's a little bit it depends a little
bit do you want simplified position do
you want a position that is more
strategic in nature but more complex
this is all kind of different you can
play the slaw for example in a very
strategic kind of fashion but you can
also play it in a super-sharp way so
what's it's not so easy to same
many players play the Slav and count
count defense against before and even
want a strategic game but I also a more
of a strategist and I don't play those
openings I mean I do play them
occasionally but not regularly I enjoy
those positions like this and with many
pieces on the board where you can
maneuver and so on this is what I enjoy
more which doesn't stop me from
sometimes blundering upon how and b5
it's almost gone yeah with free web
resources I mean stuff like chess games
calm and so on I mean these are
resources that at least can help you to
find games or get information and there
are there are more resources you can
also i think chest tempo has her side
has things but i'm not super well
informed all those things I basically do
with the database if I want to kind of
look at a certain line or position i
will ever use use chessbase okay have to
cover this he takes it has taken on c5
this is nowadays happening rather
frequently in this opening but still it
caught me a little bit by a surprise in
that precise position I absolutely don't
mind for the trades here yes Sebastian
is right there there are a couple of a
couple of database resources they are
also other database programs other than
chess space likes it which is something
that i have looked looked into but if
you mean i'm a chance based user since
the very first version here the
chessbase 11.0 and back then it didn't
even have variations or whatever i just
have the pure games and
I'm kind of so used to the software it's
difficult for me to switch to something
else okay this is a complex position I
think I would like to trade the heavy
pieces then I should be completely fine
it's it seems yeah this is possible but
I wasn't sure this is actually good for
him I mean it also beacons wide quite a
bit now he basically has to trade I mean
he can go back I'm sorry I can go back
but I don't think this is nothing much
yeah actually I chessbase 1.0 19 19 19
19 88 on the Atari so it was on the
Atari ST not on the pc sure really
sounds kind of wacky nowadays but it it
was it started on the Atari and only
later switched to pc okay so i have a
interesting position here and in fact i
have more time and now i have a pawn he
didn't pay attention tonight a 4 mp3 no
I think I'll just take this then
yeah i'm a bit luckier that he blundered
be too i mean i think the end game was
good anyway but this is way it it's just
it's just probably winning yeah maybe
that wasn't so precise actually okay
mean it's not bad but it could argue
that maybe I had a better alternative
now I can promote see is it wrapping
this I don't see it okay check it should
be 60 and d7 no I have a bishop on f6 I
have a bishop on f6 so that's not a big
problem and ok let's go over to be four
white resides ok second win against
Flamel sabita played the sky two times
now ok so now G bianchi applies always
seem to play me on the streamer kind of
every Monday ok going for quickie 3d for
against it early Bishop e7 this is not a
bad bad cell ok going into some kind of
benoni now I'm losing a movie with e3 e4
but black is not very happy with his b6
and some Bishop to be seven either maybe
this one makes Bishop g7 a little bit
more difficult to UM
to play okay I wonder this is a position
where Queen to e2 is interesting trying
to immediately irritate black I'm trying
this the idea c5 just killing basically
opening up Queenie 5 and so on this is
known from some benoni setups not sure
about it here but it could be very
irritating for black that's a question
by victor 'ok scar if i can play that
that old line which you hate it but
still plate yeah he refers to my old
chigorin wait I really don't want to
play that it really isn't great and i
think i'm mostly bore people with that
line okay so Bishop if aid how to do
that now Queen to d2 maybe keeping
keeping him from castling
okay so I think I'll go for a for now so
that be five is not happening between F
674 Queen to g7 maybe hmm difficult on
difficult to prevent idea for as an idea
probably well plata the book care where
i learned that chick over in line that
that I don't want to play anymore is
from behind mehreen the Romanian
Grandmaster it's I think a Spanish
repertoire for black or something like
that
okay night if I have interesting hmm and
night a force irritating me an IG phone
I g4s actually now I move in some cases
huh okay i was thinking g3 yes 94 very
nice okay i'm returning um any questions
here no not really ok so what to do now
maybe that g3 move not so happy with it
but he played that rather well
maybe that Bishop age six and let him
take their wasn't so great I should have
taken on evade it was probably better my
development here is not good good at all
now I think you probably has some
dynamic ideas b5 maybe our things like
that they could they could work okay
that's not so threatening at least first
side is probably intending I don't know
what f5 yeah i can actually consider a
five now but i don't want to I'd rather
play before here yes yes yes yes but
this is also weakening quite a bit o
night f5 9594 oh why didn't I see that
quickly quicker who doesn't do it
interesting okay very interesting I know
it should be okay really this okay Linda
the king is going to the side anyway ok
let's go on etsy for it's the most
obvious move and probably not bad just
attack this okay he's got night at five
but i think it's not bad to get this in
first okay um where to go with the Queen
and night on the force is always a past
it really is i want the bishop 1c4
absolutely very tough maybe it didn't
matter i think it probably has to take
on v6 no just no okay hmm
I move the night where do you go with
the bishop back ok FD six but they are
came the sex is not particularly great
looking move I can go to a area you can
go to a head mmm a d6 is opening up is
this position rather then shoot I don't
see a good move now time morning maybe
the same going looking at the e4 pawn so
i can now take this why not it should be
five I know
very very chaotic position which very
likely is good for white but since it's
so complicated that kind of anything can
happen 24 is attacking f2 yeah it's not
okay i can take the five Bishop c4 bit
it's not exactly what I wanted shoot and
how night before yeah that's stupid he
gets to take f2 right I was stupid we
didn't do it why not I have no idea
can still play 94 maybe I can still do
that no this one don't understand a
single move here check let understand
Jack Black resigns okay that was weird
that was weird um there was some some
stream issue I don't actually think that
this is my end I have cleared space and
the mail or internet connection is
pretty strong pretty good I keep playing
a loofah so it's a very high rated very
high rated person so let's see what he's
doing a some English opening 2600n you
don't see that too often
castles maybe add I actually this is an
opening that I have played with white
and forgotten most of it after three
rounds do I think that Aronian can win
the candidates yeah of course thankies
got a good start he has got a winning
against Apollo um and he looks looks
okay what he's doing him I think that's
not a brand new accountant it solid
cheating account there's a best of chess
explained video yeah i think someone
sent me a link to that once but i don't
i don't watch my own videos i really
don't ok let's go back now okay night is
six maybe not but snare cats it still
feels kind of okay to bring the night
over to this it's not a bad night
placement
I think Rufus normally has an American
flag but currently not
hmm I know it's got some yeah that's
true well my score is not bad I've got
one game one win ok would be too and
I'll just do the normal stuff here just
playing all the moves I know
yeah that looks like is pretty solid
position here for our foot black why
doesn't have a clear way forward him one
night be 30 probably just played b6 and
let him capture on c5 it's very
difficult to make any progress I can
also play 94 if you place 93 okay this
is some way forward okay I can play
Bishop f4 also let's do that start with
that move now grab the grab the exchange
you know this is not objectively enough
i guess but it's interesting in blitz
chess definitely okay um where do I go
it's commits definitely some compass on
compensation to e5 what you have six I
guess to have six can take c7 but I can
take c3 which I'm not sure is parade coo
coo CA does 97 that's a bad idea yeah 40
taking c3 looks kind of shaky I'd like
to get my bishop somehow into the game
but I don't see how
well okay I don't see how we refuse that
at the moment maybe he has some
refutation but
yeah poor tough position what is he
doing now Queens you've no Quincy for
maybe a night h6 is now a threat so just
go back
hmm didn't see that one coming so can go
look the end
I don't have no good move I didn't see
that one
I was a shame I should have played
probably be six and prevented rupee
seven altogether it's probably not that
great but it made my life much more
difficult than the necessary before that
blacks position was very comfortable
check okay hmm not sure what this is
about 95 maybe yes I now Luke see itís
actually made that was stupid anyway
there as well as a bad game I don't want
to analyze and Blitzen live in those
games much but um I think I should
probably just play b6 and this is just
totally fine for black black is just
better in this position I've got the
better structure and white has no
compensation he's got the rooks lined up
against nothing and well this is not
great but I completely misplayed it what
is the best way to do it the engine
wants to do this and just play here kick
him back that's probably good anyway
let's go for a new game the positive
thing is if you lose against someone
with 2,600 you don't lose many rating
points game started okay let's play
making no sense and kicking off with one
you form for a change yeah i'm going to
play the open sicilian which is always
funny because i have no idea what i'm
doing i would net you for maybe that
could it was probably yeah yeah that was
probably not good yeah yeah yeah okay
okay okay yeah the problem is this is
not even good this is absolutely
absolutely rubbish now because I have no
move on the bishop move the screen to be
6
okay [ __ ] sorry guys but they're now
I have to play this rotten position can
only hope for tricks like 95 Greene age
five this is actually a good trick but
yeah okay so Queen age five I guess so
that is forced to play g6 I may be
forced I don't know close to g6 so now
may be back here yeah I totally hate
this position but it is just the
consequence of my bed opening play
Bishop e3 was just too too quickly
played so what now maybe I can do this
and now this is played yeah I have to be
a very quickly I cannot waste any time
the only thing that I have is better
development so they don't care if he
gets yet another bishop so he allows me
to take these six yeah well Scott Quincy
seven things like that definitely true
am
while until it's absolutely terrible
position absolutely terrible okay maybe
this one yadi sh t am there's a remark
that I should adjust the screws on my
desk yeah probably I hope that has
gotten better after my move but kind of
it didn't yet the six is hanging out the
bad part is even if he just gives me the
pawn his position is better because of
my absolutely terrible structure and
move Bishop e3 is just completely
terrible absolutely terrible move okay
let's see what he does black and just
castle for example and this is not bad
at all maybe it's not the best move but
it's something that he can do you can
also take f3m check yeah rook chicks and
Bishop b5 I mean I can take with the
Jeep on maybe I should write hmm this is
not that clear probably is so not good
but it it felt like worse before
seagoing Bishop f8 no okay I'm not
trading Queens in this position that
much is clear okay you see three is
hanging
c4 isn't is it amazingly ugly move but
maybe I can just get the d6 phone like
that now here I've got Quincy
three-person pasta and f4f 45 hmm
interesting Oh is he going be five now i
was thinking i have e five but maybe I'm
wrong they're very much possible b5
looks kind of awkward looks very awkward
no and he's seeing it no stupid stuff I
was thinking I v5 but of course I don't
I mean I have I can play it but it's not
what i wanted to do or what I was hoping
for the result that same check I'm
taking this taking this and at least I'm
not strategically lost but still not
what I was hoping for Bishop cheeks i
guess i'm not sure what he's doing here
ok ok you can take with the poem it's
not terrible but so not what I expected
ok it's going back interesting
and I'm a pawn down yeah I didn't even
see that that's cool haha this is very
relaxed right go into an endgame up or
down without realizing your porn down I
didn't see that I was thinking as eco
material but ok the good thing is that
is that check I'm position is still
relatively solid I cannot go Ruby seven
though that's a shame that's what I
wanted to do why can I not do what I
wanted to do very bad oh yeah okay three
is a complete joke of a move I cannot do
that
I have to
time warning I wants to play fancy stuff
now that I always loved that if they
play fancy stuff instead of being
content what they have want to be fancy
yeah I mean you can't do that it's not
like it's bad okay this is a self trap
of my rook good idea check
very nice and game player he's looked
swanging me just like that check check
yeah it's kind of a waste of time right
wait I didn't see that I was a pawn down
down and I really played it badly I
think here the worst was definitely over
there was a bad plane and Quincy three
in particular was terrible I think yeah
I'm okay with this Becky King yeah i
know that this looks terrible but this
is not so bad ok anyway let's shoot for
ending game they played that they played
the technical partner and quite well
playing most carita who the heck is that
someone wants me to cut jeans go f4 I
never play one f3 you know that
somewhere for me when I don't really
like it but me well most Kira I never
played him if he go see five I will
probably play the Kings gambit Knight f6
okay
so we get that what is that called the
polar bear I will just play like this
yeah that's definitely playable and
playable position here for right hmm
that looks weird okay I'll just adds a
shoot and ask questions later this one
okay we had set up very weird setup a
black we'll see what happens I don't
believe in it Wow
that looks quite questionable mr. musk
reader will same but okay so this looks
normal threatening to take on g6 what
you just allow that now you're very cool
guy you can just allow that cool maybe
so i can check here and it isn't
supposed to mean nothing maybe that's
the case not interesting i don't think
there's a grizzly bear opening
all it's a question when when I will be
playing next against sksk ports German
German team that beat my club 88a to nil
a to nil that was really really pretty
pretty bad loss for my team well ok but
it can happen I got such a strong strong
opposing squat ok so we got into an
ending which is not bad a bit surprised
that you just just goes for that I mean
it's just a bad ending for black unless
i'm totally not understanding things i
can maybe you can take play night at
four take a look at 894 ok that's
probably a draw
hmm why is he not just instantly taking
on f2 those kind of things always
irritate me it's the totally obvious
move and somehow he doesn't play it okay
I Scott he's got that night F for IDM or
is he going for Bishop f4 even here
maybe
okay i'll go here it's a bit of a shame
neither for birds ok
okay what is he doing here I mean you
should be absolutely happy with drawing
of the night f4
okay interesting Bishop f4 but well I
can even I can just move it away to ybor
not somewhere kind of kind of weird yeah
black is thinking for a long time which
irritates me quite a bit what is this
idea is he disconnected i don't think so
i can check oh maybe I am disconnected I
currently don't get a reply here with
everywhere with my commands hmm I could
be disconnected nope hmm what happened
down there was a weird connection
village okay I'll just move it and ask
things later couldn't take him 97 maybe
I don't know
time warning
yeah I lost lots of time there was a
connection issue on my end which is a
bit of a shame the position was totally
okay I think not sure here but I
definitely it was ok before I mean I
don't don't see anything terrible
happening here either but it generally
helps to have more time
Jen
where are you going with this mister
mosquito mosket ah I don't see it where
are you going there
yeah it's a bit difficult to do much
here within four for me take care no
probably not I can go back with this
time situation that's probably not a bad
idea they are the 20 seconds of the real
problem of the position is okay of
course check each for check yeah that
that game was basically decided by the
by the connection it's not not even even
a problem here think check check
white yeah anyway b7 and everything's
fine you but I had lost more than a
minute with the disconnect yeah a bit of
a low note of the of that of that end
really don't like to end like that but i
still have eaten below 2400 that sucks
okay I'm going to play one more if
nobody is kind of objecting to that yeah
it was supposed to the shame I mean
because in that end game here black has
absolutely zilch am absolutely nothing
and then I lost here lost more than one
minute over that move um yeah in heap he
actually tried very hard to be worse and
this is always kind of kind of a shame
that you cannot do it with them with
that time then anyway let's hope I get a
game now I don't want to wait like game
start okay let's see if I can win
against mr. spender cm to get back to
2400 not 95 I keep playing this
automatically here just because of my
history with the move
I won't play three more games that will
be a bit too long i think i'm also
screwing up the overall icc schedule i
think if i would would go for that
should be three here okay that's not
very common i think but ok this is the
brass i'm still playing this by ear ok
hmm so c4 here or not probably i can
also go before just shut the whole thing
down but i think given the chance i'll
play see for me ok see shooting for f4
here it would be surprising I mean
currently you cannot cannot do it anyway
ok so here let me go back for Bishop f6
and Bishop g5 try to get rid of the dark
squared bishop ok you have to after
lever immediately and get this traded
yeah Bishop g5 you can take on c5 this
is always interesting i never really
know what to make off that trade I'm not
very afraid of it but still ok I'll keep
this under control my ambition my queen
Queen d2 was I was more afraid of Queen
d2 ok one now now he's playing that ok
right he's playing that ok
Bishop c8 and I don't like it it's
probably not terrible for me but not
ideal at least that was quick about it I
was quick about it no I never play the
marshal a check I think the marshal is
in is a terribly impractical opening for
for most players for professionals it's
cool but for normal people i think it's
it's kind of it's kind of you know it's
it's tons of work it really is it's tons
of work to to get it to a reasonable
level and and then you never get it on
the board because they play all kinds of
wacky sidelines and and i don't see the
point really and many lines are just
very draw it's also something that can
be a problem in at a certain level okay
see aiming where you see going with this
not sure about it
and I don't think that this ending can
be a problem I'm going all the way to g5
maybe I cannot do something positive
that's possible but I don't have any
problem in the brain the site's f are
rather different there can be there can
be some transpositions but rather really
yeah that will be very difficult to do
something with some gym
okay not happy with that but check I'm a
bit surprised that you did that but ok
we'll see what happens maybe I should
nice ok [ __ ] Bishop age three maybe
would pin I'm pinning pin and win but
I'm not sure that this is a pinhead win
situation Bishop f4 I wonder I wonder if
I in this position if I take and play
Bishop f4 mmm do I win this this this
this it could be winning actually i'll
try this not sure if it's a draw ok what
the heck
I'm getting the c3 porn which means two
connected passes maybe you can stop at
them it's really possible I can stop
them the pawns I mean check that didn't
help so back here so I can invade now
right
full-scale invasion and see three wins
right yeah I guess I'm ending this so I
got to precisely 2400 at the end of the
stream that's good okay so I think it's
better to end the whole thing with the
wind then with some stupid law so it was
mostly due to disconnect I hope you
enjoyed the stream there wasn't that
much action in the chat at the end maybe
we had a little bit less spectators
sedate from Europe due to the time
change I'm very happy about all the
regulars coming for the stream thank you
all for watching and participating in
the chat bye bye till next week